torrential rain and severe weather has
caused widespread flooding across
several parts of bosnia-herzegovina
burying cars houses and damaging roads
and facilities the country is no
stranger to floods and landslides but
people say the sheer amount of rain
that's fallen in the past 48 hours has
been unexpected
all of a sudden the rain started falling
and within 10 minutes cars were covered
by water and all of this the breeze came
in
in the towns of konits and yablaniza
south of the capital sarajevo heavy
machinery was brought in to clear the
streets but many roads will still need
to be repaired before they can be used
again emergency services have been
deployed across this municipality as
well as other areas of the country
people and machines are working hard to
repair the damage this is only one of
the many affected locations
along the neretva river a popular
tourist location restaurants and
businesses have also been hit hard
despite having a robust drainage system
built to weather storms the amount of
water proved too much the entire
drainage system has been clogged up we
could not clean it fast enough what can
you do thankfully no one was hurt and
thank god it's only material damage that
can hopefully be repaired
the local mayor who was on site
monitoring the situation told al jazeera
that by friday afternoon some 60
truckloads of debris had been removed
but several towns in the area remained
cut off with roads leading in and out of
them unusable
the amount of rain that's fallen in the
last 36 hours equals the amount that
usually falls during an entire month
many businesses at homes have been
damaged but it's too early to assess the
full extent
on a national level the government has
stopped short of announcing a state of
emergency but says the situation is
serious
people here are taking it upon
themselves to fortify their homes
stacking sandbags and other objects to
fend off against the floods
whilst the most severe damage caused by
the floods has been outside of sarajevo
here in the capital the rainfall has
been consistent raising river levels and
as a result fears that unless the
weather improves parts of the city too
could be flooded
jamal al-shayal al jazeera sarajevo